welcome to the course on jQuery I'm
excited to be able to take you through a
quick tour of the jQuery library over
60% of the top 100,000 most visited
websites take advantage of jQuery simple
syntax and powerful Dom manipulation
methods in this course you'll experience
firsthand why jQuery is so popular as
you explore the features that it has to
offer you'll start by breaking down how
the jQuery library is built with
JavaScript and what that means for your
code then you'll dive into jQuery
selectors and Dom navigation methods
this is probably the trickiest and most
important part of learning jQuery but
once you've mastered selectors you'll be
parsing the jQuery documentation to
write simple and straightforward Dom
manipulation code there are a lot of
quizzes in this course so you'll have
plenty of practice manipulating the Dom
with jQuery as you go are you ready to
get started